das gotthardmassiv es war einst das
größte hindernis zwischen nord und süd
europa der berg stand personen und
gütern im weg musste mühsam bezwungen
werden
heute geht es ganz einfach durch das
mauseloch mitten in den berg als würde
das tal ins gestein hinein verlängert
kilometer 0 das ist er also der neue
gotthard basistunnel kilometerweise
beton kabel gleise ab und zu ein
lüftungsschacht
bei unserer durchfahrt ist für eine
bessere sicht die notbeleuchtung
eingeschaltet so wird die schweizer
massarbeit im gotthard deutlich und
trotzdem das alles wirkt irgendwie
ziemlich unspektakulär ein tunnel leben
und doch nicht irgendein tunnel der
gotthard basistunnel ist jetzt der
längste eisenbahntunnel der welt
er verbindet rotterdam und genua zürich
und mailand
europa rückt mit der neuen verkehrsader
näher zusammen
und dieses zusammenwachsen europas ist
teuer
jeder meter tunnel kostet mehr als
200.000 in schweizer franken
nächster halt sieht ruhen hier liegt
eine der vier not haltestellen untertage
brennt es im tunnel oder kommt es zu
einem anderen notfall können sich die
passagiere hier auf notbetten dann
öffnen sich auch die grünen fluchttüren
und geben den weg frei in die sichere
flucht röhre nebenan
wir nehmen gleich mal einen solchen
fluchtweg
dann kommen wir in einem haus hohen
dunklen lüftungsschacht und dann zu
einzigen offenen stelle des bergs keine
beton verschalung kein pflaster liegt
hier auf der offenen wunde des gotthards
in einem kleinen see sammelt sich das
tropfende wasser aus dem berg über eine
treppe geht es nach unten ans ufer
da schwimmt ein bauarbeiterhelm im see
wohl unachtsam zurückgelassen
darüber eröffnet sich ein dunkles loch
zum berg und lässt die gesteinsmassen
erahnen die auf dem gotthard basistunnel
lasten für immer im berg versenkt
bleiben gut 15 millionen schweizer
franken
sie wurden schon in die wartehallen der
porta alpina investiert 800 meter unter
sedrun im kanton graubünden sollte
nämlich mitten im gotthard basistunnel
der tiefste bahnhof der welt entstehen
als verbindung zum alpinen tourismus ort
heute erinnern nur noch zwei dunkle
aushöhlungen im berg an dem geplatzten
traum versperrt mit schwarzem
eisengittern und waren hinweisen
betreten verboten
auch hinter gittern in einer nische
steht eine statue der heiligen barbara
sie ist die schutzpatronin der bergleute
und mineure unabhängig von ihrer
nationalität oder konfession würdigen
die mineure ihre schutzheilige mit einem
kurzen blick einem kleinen dankeschön
einem stoßgebet einmal im jahr immer am
vierten dezember findet die santa
barbara feier statt
dann wird der opfer am berg gedacht
[Musik]
nach 800 metern durch den
versorgungsschacht sind wir in zitronen
angekommen und fliegen jetzt richtung
faido
das schneebedeckte gotthardmassiv was
für ein panorama 2300 meter unter diesen
felsen verläuft der gotthard basistunnel
tiefer als jeder andere tunnel der welt
und tief im tunnel bekommt man überhaupt
nichts mit von der naturgewalt dieser
berge
wir passieren jetzt die kantonsgrenze
zwischen graubünden und dem tessin bis
im jahr 1803 hat die schweiz hier
aufgehört
jetzt sind wir offiziell im süden wir
tauchen wieder ablassen uns ins dunkel
fallen
[Musik]
nächster und letzter halt faido
bitte folgen sie der fluchtweg
bestellung bis zur warte zone von der
warte zone raus werden sie dann
weiterfahren
sie befinden sich in einem sicheren
bereich
bitte helfen sie sich gegenseitig und
befolgen sie die anweisungen des
personals
hoffentlich muss diese ansage nie
eingespielt werden außer zum test zu
hören ist sie über das soundsystem des
tunnels und dass dieses system
funktioniert haben die ingenieure immer
und immer wieder getestet
statt der durchsage ließen sie dabei
musik laufen
zur abwechslung und wohl auch um die
nerven zu schonen
sie wählten aber nicht irgendeine musik
sondern den letzten satz der neunten
sinfonie von ludwig van beethoven die
europahymne
[Musik]
kilometer 57 die berge mit ihrem ewigen
schnee liegen hinter uns der gotthard
einst das größte hindernis europas ist
heute einfach ein tunnel
[Musik]